来,我给大家吹逐一,从此以后,命认得死不得开学宣传
这条视频是分享跟我们老伙子的,因为我们老伙子还知道我们在说什么
如何一边学习,然后一边转点小鲜,这都是打开率的事
首先我们要讲就是拍摄短视频,这件事他是一个负产品
最重要的是什么是能够提升你的认识
因为有些时候你不需要掌握太多的知识,有些真正关键的知识,一旦你理解了
然后你的视约关,就会发生在那边,从而改变的行为
然后你的行为会产生的那个行为,结果是由你的行为产生的
但是首先你的思想上要有一些理解
所以独一些书,独一些好书,认真的去理解
而不是表面的表面的意思,对吧
就是我们很多人会有那种感受,我说我这些知识我都懂
但是我说不来我今天在直播的时候跟大家分享了,那是因为你不懂
因为所有的书记的那种知识,他在写的功能,他是有计法的
比如说你你们去看很多关于写作的书,不知拍摄短视频,都会告诉你该怎么开错
就是怎么把用户信进来,然后有华品的问题,就是告诉你怎么读下去
这几无所有的写作的书拍电影,都会这样,所以有些时候你能看懂是
因为人家已经给了你只是爬了,有人否则你
但是一旦你自己想的过程中,注意你的怪仗没了,所以你不会
就我们可能会有用错,就认为自己不懂了,就会就明白了
但实际上你会发现真正的读懂是要会掉用的
你不会掉用就是不懂,对吧,今天我给大家举个例子,对吧,你有一个
你有一个手机,这个手机干嘛,应该打电话了
但这个电话你打不了电话,那你这个手机就没用
各位,那名貌的意思吗
所以我们一定要真正的理解的一个知识,而这个知识是非常重要的知识
那你的人生就会发生改变,有忙额老师说过一句话就让你变得富有的方法非常简单
就是找到什么东西是有用的知识,反复的就掉过它
什么东西是没用的知识,把他生掉
所以各位,你去找一些比较好的数,比如想拿玩耳、导演、比如说小人美,比如说从来
比如说区别的工具,都很好
但是这里边可能会有一些版权的问题
所以我们老火,我给大家建议你可以去读我的数议
因为我写这个数的时候我其实还是非常用心的
很多知识在区所的时候我是这样区所的
它应该是非常简单的
但是一旦你理解了,就会对你的生活带来去打改变
不是知道是你真正理解了,真正把它用到你的形容中
你就会带来就要打改变
而且就是你们用我的数议的知识的话
我不会告诉你,就不会有版权的问题
所以大家可以开始可以用价值心拿你的知识
然后慢慢你习惯了以后,你可以用其他的一些好数的知识
怎么做?首先第一件事情,你会发现要越往后,这个越有意思
而且越有价值
我们先说前面这个部分,就是你在读书的时候
不要贪打球权,不要贪快
你给先看一下牧路
这个牧路里面哪个知识你最感兴趣
或者你最吸缺
今天开播之前的话呢
我是想到点说的
开播之前,开直播之前,然后有个老婆
你就问我一个问题,说胡子哥
就是我呢,就是学过怎么做灯光
怎么拍摄短视频,怎么研究一下
怎么美学,我学了好多好多个学生
但是我仍然赚不到钱,为什么
然后我就问他,你学这些东西的牧标
不要是版杂,他说变现,我说那你变现了
就是你这么长时间的干什么,你在学习,你没有去变现
所以你变不了钱,你的时间花在哪,你的收益就在哪
对吧,你的时间的干嘛都花去学习了
所以你在学习的很便宜,是十六千别人的
那么我们在看知识说也是一样,各位在讲什么
先感,不是先学,一定要抛弃那种
我学完了,我学的系统以后的感,不要
这是我们上学时的此理,叫硬试教育
我们要做的是什么,我们要做的是发挥自己的场响,先去干先馆成
遇到问题,学什么?
所以各位,你可以翻到这个说里面,你看哪些东西是你真正需要的
不用什么都道理看
这个东西,你觉得对你是非常重要的,就翻到那一切
注意,我没有说翻到这一张,翻到那一切
就只需要这一切,然后你找到这一切里面
这一切的标题和这一切加黑的部分
我既然能把他加出,一定是因为加出这个部分很重要
所以你就可以看,重点是加出这个部分就什么案件
也就是说这一张里面,这个部分很重要
但是我既然把的加出,不会说就是
莫名其妙的加出的
一定是前面,后面都是为了讲这个一句
所以的话,你就看这一句话,对你有没有帮助
然后前面,后面都是在讲这句话的
有于你理解
如果在读的过程中,你没有感觉,不要紧,换下一个
换下一个,可能对你有针对我帮助的认真理解
一旦你选择,一定要认真理解
甚至是一个字一个字的理解
然后理解这段的概念
然后你还要进行主题的读
就看看其他说里面,还讲对方的内容
好了注意,你要做两件事
你这段不完了以后,你看看哪句话
对你的思想产生的影响
你觉得这句话讲得太棒了
然后你把这种话写出来
然后写的过程中去,你就想
说这段话对我有什么帮助
和我一望的知识,和我的生活
到底有什么样的联机,你把他写出来
写了个小最大的回来,一句话两句话都可以
然后你再去思考
这个地方我理解完了以后,哪些东西可以把它变成我的行为
如果一个知识没有把它变成行为,这个知识
其实大概你就费掉了
所以你一定要把它变成行为
我后面要变成什么的行为
然后这个对句话
所以给我带来什么的改变,你用这样一个改变之后
这个时候这个东西对你有用了
主要这个地方高能来过
如果你有时间我给你个小建议
就是张忆在读书的时候,你把吃多打开
这个时候不要关注在行为多少人
这个东西都是负产品都不重要
把直播打开
然后打开的过程中,然后把手机靠到一边
甚至你可以用什么
可以用社交头的后置镜头
这样你就看不到本次了
对吧
他就不会影响,你只是把他打开
然后这个时候你就开始认诺书
你就认诺书了
然后你在读书的时候
有感觉的时候
你可以给大家分享一下
比如说我最近在读谋一边
谋一边书这位书留一段
我觉得特别感受
我和大家分享一下
然后我的感受是什么
看大家的恢复
然后在这个地方就交流
就是理解这个只是
包括下面有很多很多的文字
所以你包括有那些行动
注意这个时候
其实你把这边书掛到你的出创
有可能啊
有可能
你已经想了特别有道理
人家就会问你
你多的来本书
你说我出创理的那本书
这本书的第一届验
我给大家分享一下
可能这本书就卖掉
我们社区里边已经有老火腰
结果咱们卖书的
一天差不多可以卖掉
一百本
一个里
但确实是存在这样一种情况
然后你通过这个方式的话
你就可以学习去理解
然后
你又感觉了以后
下了直播之后
把直播一关拿起相机
就把你的感受
就把你的对这个东西的理解
然后把它拍出来
就变成了一条视频
所以各位
这个时候你会发现
播放量也好
还是是不是卖书也好
直播街也没有人
也好
这个都不重要
这些东西都是复杂的
更抓的是你真正的一切
一个知识
因为一旦你一切的
知识你的人就进化了
一旦你成为在什么样的人
就必然有和这个人
相批配的
财富
说明你
这个才是不难再外讲
我记得盲格更好的个才是怎么说的
盲格说的是
怎么又一样东西呢
最好的方式是
让自己
配得上的